you
all right we're ready to go here for the
Hank arena many viewers in the twitch
chat suggested I name this king of the
hill tournament the Hank arena one
minutes chess first player to get their
King on one of the four center squares
as a winner
ah you have to be careful the King might
just go for some mad dash towards the
center
let's see
hold off on castling do not be too quick
to castle
cleans off when there's two fixed prawns
like this it's really tough to sneak in
with the King kind of watch out
that night
mm yeah actually I don't know if I want
to take okay we're definitely going the
King definitely go with the king
you take me that way I get this square
get rid of the night
and take with the pawn I like my
position give me this square I'm gonna
win it's a win by force I got to stop me
from getting there
got a tricky move rook here tricky and I
always pre move interference tactic baby
I love it
alright I was a fast one I'm sorry I'm
sorry I didn't mean to call you baby
that doesn't happen often did he just
say baby oh man it's really not that
funny man what is so funny about that
word nobody knows we're gonna Castle
we're gonna go here and baby step it
fast track towards the center with my
king now still gonna centralize put a
king in the center put a knight in the
center holy cow um I don't know take
here and then take here
let's sneak up just a hair mm-hmm oh I
got something fancy queen takes is gonna
take the bishop
Oh mate next can't stop it kingi form
back to tournament lands we got 449
players in this one nice
okay kill Jerry the second isn't first
okay
kill Jerry the second not sure why I
started with Knight to f3 already Bishop
here I'm just going to leave him sitting
give me a nice grip over the dark
squares and for king of the hill
purposes I think the king would camp out
really nice on the III point
let's uh let's
them to maybe take or backup
shoes hmm let's sneak up I was going to
do that before going here anyhow
I'll take him
they're gonna give me this square its
mate next if they take my night cannot
take care III I just want this square I
don't know kind of passing
and now we take here and then we take
here
one through
gotta go here push game over back
determine
can I always pre-move a king to one of
the four center squares somebody told me
that once there's no harm all right this
is probably our first time playing king
of the hill
I wanna clog this up
can I take my night my name
and take with the night
and taken it the night
yeah
yeah this is this is scary
I guess we'll go here I could weather
the weather a storm I think got there
my queen
that Square too easily
you
skies so fast men
I should have oh there we go
another clearance tactic watch out for
the clearance tactics very deadly
yeah those clearance tactics come up
quite a bit in king of the hill I've
noticed
not just this tournament foot past
experienced plenty of games
the OL Queen sack just to open up that
square that was pretty sweet
I like that one
let's push him around get my f-pawn
playing let's open this up take this
pawn out
quite up
take with the king I have a check
it's my king of scooting over just yet
let's give a check I have another check
I could be giving scoop my king up he is
closer
okay I think I have everything covered
my king
keep him cut off and got to keep
laughs
Oh what am i doing would you just
calculate one two you dummy oh my god
why did it take so long to realize you
just exchanged rooks and work in the
center I was trying to be fancy maybe
we'll give a check let's give a check
and then if he takes I take what my upon
no exchange rooks and win space is very
nice there's added value with space in
king of the hill
now if they try this he's a trapped
knight on two three let's just go here
straight away they're gonna kill the
dark square Bishop that's their plan
Bishop g5 or is it I have the B form
not anymore that they're no longer in a
pin
alright let's push here
my kraut let's grab some more space
I'm controlling the whole board here and
then g5 we might just be looking for a
checkmate right around this point let's
step the King up
okay more space how does their king ever
get out actually I probably should have
done this let's do it now
I could smash through forget king of the
hill at this point we're going for mate
let's take a moment out to recapture
okay now we go here and then mate like
this I could take the night I'm going
hunting I don't want the rook got the
King 20 with fire 20 minutes left 64
players in here all right we got to stay
away from this guy right here who again
next kill Jerry to is in a game nice all
right this guy again okay yeah this is
the
played him a couple games back all right
hmm they don't have any pawns
controlling their fourth rank so I'll
step up
I go here I think they might do one of
those moves
losing let's get this guy here
let's take like this and give this check
let's step up
doing this
let's go here and then I want to go here
I think I need to secure that they're
ready to maybe take a couple times
huh
it's kind of scary
I could have captured here
my king is far away
let's block it up
um come on King I could take that pawn I
don't know if I want to maybe I do I
want to now can we take not sure why I
did that
you
I got this square Oh No holder down in
time they're so close to getting in
there somehow oh if you analyze that
game I think I think they probably had
some forced win it certainly felt like
that burrito man
playing on multiple players very close
to each other the same guys right
burrito men
stop Bishop g4 secure for a little bit
okay I'm cool it out
hums castle put the bishop here in d3
grab some space clamp down
structure develop a bishop
go in that pond no reason I shouldn't
have done that
okay take what the pond wrote to be one
now that Queens cooked she's a goner
there's no way the king is getting in
here back to tournament it's too blocked
up Queen for rook that's gonna be way
too much
all right we're locked in there at 64
it's pretty much where we're gonna stand
so I'm at 28
2824 okay the murder castle
first time playing this guy in this
variant all right
let's see
hmmm let's flush him out of there that's
that's just
see how they feel
this
is this Bishop is a monster come on take
that pawn man
let's do this they're going to try and
sacrifice here
now I can't get like run right up here
the plan how you stopping him he's
really quick
he um he sees it he's too fast
he just resigned I am take over see for
next throw my king on d5 and that's a
wrap
all right there's an important one arc
of 50 I see is in there
here we go London action
control a center square
give me some space
hmm
back off
I have ugly ponds but this is good even
in regular chess I think
step up oh here maybe goddess keep
defending this
[Music]
okay
yeah and step up one
yeah
Stephan's
I want here
I could play my king right here which is
really close to winning many variations
if he ever leaves and since flushing boy
might sacrifice here no they're in the
think tank
let's just keep throwing pawns all right
yeah there's that move I missed that one
I could take here there not much time
oh the night's gonna go there stay in
the center King I could do this
tougher mates
watch out for mates
you
oh oh I don't even realize I'm like oh
they dropped the rook no they dropped
the rookie other King King takes rook
mate king of the hill style all right we
got 12 minutes left that's still a lot
of games 36 with fire
oh man king of the hill
I guess we'll try caro-kann
and although probably not a good idea
because I'm immediately giving them
space
[Music]
I guess here
okay
yeah let's let's try to weasel into this
square this is extremely important I
hang on to this pawn Queen has to go
back to c1 didn't oh that's not that's
not correct what I just did there not
cool
oh man they could probably take here and
then run up
yeah I hear you man
I am nowhere close to getting in the
center I think I need this Oh
I was on that pond it's scary I don't
see how they could get in there
you
I just want to dance around a little bit
with my night
that's a fork and we flush them back now
we can move forward here and then here
next back determine hmm I need to stay
away from the Carroll because the
advance variation against the care on
this is uh it's good for black pretty
sure very good for white okay
the murder the murder castle
they could have captured there in the
previous move I think
okay let's take and put my knight here
how about
okay I have a lot of space on a space
mmm-hmm that here's a threat
they missed it
just want some trades man mmm I want my
night here
I'm missing something here Bishop takes
pawn as a move but they're in an
uncomfortable pin aren't they
and he gets to run
he's really fast
let's do this come on King
just cut them off rook takes Bishop is a
threat
decoy
if I took the night the king up here was
maybe a little scary I didn't want to
invite that King another step towards
the center all right 44 29 28
eight minutes left 73 are now in here
insert check
they're a let's go with now I need I
need to take up a pawn presence in the
center much sooner
being keto what else is he gonna do
they're giving me that pond but I have
to be careful of this okay then we
jumped in here
jump in again castle and how about we
get ready for this push get my king
towards the center
all right now on next move king of seven
it's not too scary even with the Queen's
on
now slip I think that was a mouse slope
only two steps out
okay I could still maintain this with my
bishop
on a fleshly King away
keep that pawn around I have
I don't know if I want to do that that's
a check
let's let's push here King up next
really close to a bishop move Bishop
here no Queen takes with check take with
the night I got two squares Bishop here
is a threat Bishop to c4 yeah they're in
big trouble get that rook out of there
just cover that when I keep my king
right where he's at
and now that
and then King here next there down on
time though
yeah there's a lot to calculate as soon
as that king is even two steps away
there are plenty of cases where there's
just a main to threat just being two
steps away from the force center all
right under six
this one's flying by
let's try d4 again
you could really go for too much variety
thinking in the hell that's why I'm
going for this setup which i think is
excellent for king of the hill
I'll take with the bishop
and go with the pond okay inside castle
with the F pond
no longer
think is nice want them to take me okay
so take hmm take here and then
do like this but here and then a queen
exchange
yikes
oh boy I need to scoop my king up there
King is gonna be much faster now if
their King moves I could move am I going
to be there in time force them back and
then get my king up I'm getting there
it's a making - threat
I got it back determine who glad I saw
the check and then the rip block
caPSURE force the king back because they
were gonna inch their way over I
initially thought about rookie 3f tree
as felt too slow four minutes left
okay
let's keep on going
one or two
more games left d5
all right we're gonna get some space
soon oh I could have grabbed that pawn
I don't even want to insert the check
let's see okay I want to lock down on
this square
h4
I induced that pawn advance
I want to stop this break so far so good
now I'm paving the way for a king run
all the way up here let's do one step
they have to give a bishop check they
didn't now they have to push they didn't
I got it back to turn
kingi six probably wasn't correct
because of e5
but they didn't see it so 250 left
fishy fishy all right I got some space I
like it
and let's secure efore
let's go here I want to drop my knight
back soon
actually I don't know what my king is on
h2 that's silly
what's that move about
let's get my knight up
going really fast let's try this I want
more space I did something similar in
the last game they give me this square
Bishop takes Knight I got that square
let's go here let's go back
not sure what I'm doing with that move
let's get this rook over here I'm gonna
play up for
hmm step out
they could take here actually
they could still take their I want to
get into b6
and just centralize
I could have captured that pawn
I want to break this down
you
not the most accurate
you
be really careful now
when I flush that guy away
you
why did I do that
you
holy cow with 0.38 and I got it
oh I don't know if it connor for the
tournament no I think I'm for the
tournament oh my god my heart is racing
holy cow that was just a rat race at the
end oh man sorry if I got a little too
loud there mmm oh that was really really
really really really close really close
okay 80 in all 56:33 3330
let's go through the pages are quick
here
all right three four where are we at
king of the hill is a blast king of the
hill and three check I really enjoy in
960
I'm just a chess fan I like em all
except for racing kings Oh in very small
doses okay
79 of you good games all right
you